-Thanks to Radcliffe
and to Judith
for your generous introduction.
And to Rebecca and
Sharon for making things
so easy for all of us here.
And to my fellow Fellows for
your engaging and challenging
companionship over this
year-- which feels to
me like a long sea voyage.
The sort I always wanted
to take-- not a cruise
on a cruise ship going
nowhere, but a crossing
on a great liner.
Like the France, and
the United States,
or the Empress of Canada--
crossing some important ocean
to a destination I have
not visited before.
I am the old guy on
deck, wrapped in my rug,
in my deck chair reading
novels, looking out for whales
and flying fish.
And dreaming of-- I
don't know-- France?
Something.
It is wonderful being
at sea with you people.
So thank you.
And I'm going to
talk about my books.
Though there's not much more
to say after what Judy said.
But first of all, I'm just
going to talk a little bit--
because some people
here are wondering what
this fellowship is all about.
And I thought I'd
talk about-- so let
me offer two scenes from
Radcliffe The Reality Show.
One is from November.
This happened shortly after
the Lucia and Raul's talk.
They are cosmologists.
Their project is understanding
the nature of the universe.
My project is a
novel about teenagers
in Quebec in the 1960s.
So post-Raul and
Lucia, I had a bit
of a morale problem going on.
I was a little intimidated.
And just before Raul and Lucia
and the nature of the universe,
Philip Klein delivered
a talk and I still
don't know what an algorithm is.
But his delight in mathematics
was contagious-- almost
contagious.
So there I was-- OK,
this is this first scene
of Radcliffe The Reality
Show-- back in November.
Late November late
night-- not late night,
evening-- in my office
surrounded by the brainiacs
on the second floor.
The door's shut.
I'm grinding away at a chapter.
And I gradually become
aware of disturbances--
shouting, rowdiness
noise out in the hall.
And this is Radcliffe, right?
It's Raul, it's
Lucia, it's Philip.
I think Robert Huber was
there too, and Tina Duhaime.
Radcliffe was
getting really rowdy.
I mean it's coming into my
office-- heated and loud.
Call the prefacts-- you
know, there's some laughter.
But they are really
trash talking out there.
It's like listening
to a call-in show
on Boston Sports Radio--
it's that kind of tone,
that kind of volume.
But it's not about the Sox, or
the Patriots, or the Celtics,
or the Bruins.
They are out there
in the hallway,
yelling at each other about
contemporary issues in brain
science, mathematics
and cosmology.
So this is what life is like
on the second floor at Byerly.
One more scene, then
I'll get to my books.
This is Martin Luther King Day.
Byerly was very, very quiet.
There no one else
here, I thought.
Me-- I'm working in my office.
My son Henry was spending
the afternoon with me.
He knows his way
around here now.
He likes riding the elevator,
because elevators are
rare on our peninsula in Maine.
He likes the hot chocolate
made steamed milk
from the machine in the kitchen
on the first floor-- many of us
do.
Anyway, middle of the
afternoon he's hungry
and I have neglected
to bring a snack.
But he's cased the building
and found a vending machine
in the basement.
Can we get a snack
out of the machine?
I don't like vending machine
snacks, but I'm feeling guilty.
Now just a little aside--
Henry was raised in Maine
by two parents who consider
themselves biophiles.
Basha grows vegetables for
our family in her garden.
We're mostly vegetarian.
We compost everything.
In our Cambridge apartment
across the street
from Harvard Law, we poured
the compost in the freezer.
I carry frozen lumps of it
to Radcliffe twice a week
on my bike through the snow.
So we're organic.
But this boy is hungry,
and I forgot snacks,
and there's a vending machine
in the goddamned basement,
and I'm in the middle
of a paragraph.
So we go down in the
basement together
and the vending machine
looks like a food morgue.
Henry points to a bag of
Doritos inside the machine.
It's a buck and a quarter
for the Doritos-- $1.25.
OK, I never buy in this stuff.
And I've obviously blown
it with the snacks.
But it's a holiday, right?
Not that I think for
a minute Doctor King
would have approved, but
I go through my pockets.
Henry looks hopeful.
I find a buck.
I can't find a quarter.
I don't have a quarter.
Sorry-- hate to
disappoint the guy.
He shrugs-- he's a good guy.
We head back to my office,
elevator to the second floor.
And I notice Michael
Pollan's door
is ajar-- next office to mine.
I haven't seen Michael
around for a couple of weeks,
but he's back.
No one else in the building--
as far as I can tell-- only
Michael Pollan, author of
The Omnivore's Dilemma.
In defense of food, and cooked.
Michael Pollan, our
most articulate critic
of agribusiness in the
destructive and precarious
agricultural system
that has wrought havoc
upon the diet, nutrition,
and well-being of Americans.
And for about 10 seconds, as
we were walking down the hall,
I'm thinking, are
you really going
to ask Michael Pollan for a
quarter to buy a bag of Doritos
from the vending
machine in the basement?
And somehow-- though I was aware
it would've been a great story
to tell at the farmer's
market this summer in Maine--
I just could not
do it to Michael.
So I didn't.
We hunted through
my office and we
found some Hawaiian macadamia
nuts called Mauna Loas-- which
are apparently kind of junk
food from Hawaii that Chris
had left out for everyone in
the kitchen before Christmas.
And those worked.
So we left Michael alone.
I want to talk a
bit about process--
where my books started, what
inspired me to write them.
And I'll read a very short
passage from each one.
I finished three novels.
The third, Carry Me, is
being published next month.
I'm working on a fourth here.
All the books are rooted in
my family's story, or stories.
Things I observed or
stories people told.
Some of the stories
probably were true.
Some were already myth
when I heard them.
Those inherited
stories and myths seem
to be where I got
started, but my books
are novels not memoires.
Characters start as people
I know, or once knew,
and along the way become
entirely themselves.
I let this happen.
It seems to have to happen.
I don't think there's
anything particularly
original about this
way of working.
Starting with
something that happened
or something someone
said, and then
inventing-- or trying to
find my way closer to things
that I'll never actually know.
Writing fiction seems a more
interesting and enlightening
way to try to comprehend
the dead generations
and their various claims on
myself than any other method
of inquiry available to me.
The Law of Dreams is set during
the Irish famine in the 1840s.
The protagonist
is Fergus O'Brien.
I think of him as my
great-great-grandfather,
of whom I know basically
nothing-- other than that he
was an O'Brien from East
Clare who came up the Saint
Lawrence on a ship sailing
from Liverpool to Quebec
in the 1840s.
But when I was
writing the novel,
I always thought of this
guy-- this protagonist--
as my ancestor.
And therefore my son
Henry's ancestor.
And that's Henry on his
first day in Dublin--
which is a big deal for me
and for my family-- walking
in moose moccasins, made
especially for him by a woman--
a Dene woman in
Northern Saskatchewan--
so those are very Canadian feet
he's putting on Irish ground.
But it was a happy
day for all of us.
We were there on The
Law of Dreams book tour.
Let's see if I do this right.
That was the first
jacket of the book.
It's been around in
a bunch of languages
which has kind of been fun.
Love the Italian cover.
That's my grandfather.
I don't remember anyone
in my family ever talking
about the famine.
And I don't remember ever
not knowing about it.
In my family we were
not into being Irish.
My grandfather, John
Joseph O'Brien-- this guy--
was the first
warden of Ascension
of our Lord parish in Montreal.
He was in the
construction business.
And he named his four daughters
Mary Margaret, Mary Althea,
Mary Frances, and Mary Patricia.
But somehow we weren't Irish.
We were Canadian.
And we were.
And there are a lot of
reasons why Irish-Canadians
became Canadian faster
than Irish-Americans
became American.
And I won't go into them
here, but believe me--
anything too Irish was
scorned in my family.
"Leprechauny" was
one adjective used.
It's very hard for me to imagine
my grandfather river dancing.
Nonetheless, the ghosts were
there-- the dead generations.
This rock-- I'll just
read what it says--
"To preserve from desecration
the remains of 6,000 immigrants
who died of ship
fever AD 1847-'48.
This stone is erected by the
workmen of Messieurs Peto,
Brassey and Betts employed
in the construction
of the Victoria Bridge AD 1859."
The story is when
they were building
the footings for the
Victoria Bridge--
the first bridge across the
Saint Lawrence at Montreal--
the workmen by accident opened
the gravepits from the famine
summer twelve summers before,
and covered them up again.
And rolled this rock over
them, and it's been ever since.
There's some dispute as
to the exact whereabouts
of the gravepits and
how many people there.
But the rock is there--
no doubt-- I've seen it.
It was put up by workmen.
And when I was Henry's
age, we sometimes
went for Sunday
drives in my family.
This seems a
bizarre concept now.
But people used to do
this-- get in the car
and drive around
the city, sometimes
with their grandparents.
And once by accident,
heading I think,
for Victoria Bridge,
and Saint-Lambert
on the South Shore,
we happened to drive
past this rock in a part of
Montreal called Griffintown--
which hardly exists anymore,
but was at one point
the Irish slum in Montreal.
And it's very near the wharves
where the famine people came.
And something happened
when we went by this place.
I remember it.
I was eight or nine.
My grandfather-- I think of
him like hissing or spitting.
But what probably
happened was he
made a sign of the cross
or something in the car.
And I felt radiating
through him from this place,
that this is a
place of some sort
of dark and shameful memory.
Really a place of a
memory of poverty,
and disinheritance, and
disregard, and shame.
And I picked that up.
He picked it up, and I
picked it up through him.
I don't believe the past
felt any different than now.
I believe the past felt
shockingly contemporary
to those living in it.
I believe they felt as we do
that they were on the cutting
edge of the human
experience, careening
into the great unknown of
the next moment, next hour,
next day.
This is my way of saying
when I write about the past I
try to avoid teleology.
The piece I'm going to read
is set not in Ireland-- piece
from The Law of Dreams-- not
in Ireland, but in Liverpool.
In the fabulous complex
of the Liverpool docklands
which were built on the slave
trade and the cotton trade.
The structures of the modern
industrial and commercial age
are well in place in
Liverpool in the 1840s.
But it's a world
dragging ancient roots.
And the Irish are dragging
ancient roots of their own
when they flood into
Liverpool in the '40s
because they can get a cheap
passage to America there.
In a few years everyone will
be crossing the Atlantic
in scheduled sailings,
packets, and steamers--
recognizably modern
ways of traveling.
But in 1847 the cheap passage is
on ships in the Canadian lumber
trade-- three-masted barques,
there's hundreds of them.
It's a one-way trade.
Canada exports lumber,
the holds go back empty.
The masters realize that with
thousands of desperate Irish
looking for passages across what
they call the Western Ocean,
they can sell space in the
holds of their lumber ships.
And that's what they do.
They knock together
really primitive bunks.
They think for
about five minutes
about how to feed these people
and how to take care of them
on an ocean crossing.
They sell tickets-- three
pounds a head is the going
rate in the summer of '47.
They pack the boats full of
people, and they set off.
And these become
the coffin ships.
Because a lot of people
are already carrying
typhus when they come aboard.
And of course the
environment in these ships
is perfect for its spread.
So it becomes a pretty
desperate summer.
And thousands and thousands
and thousands of these people
come up the Saint
Lawrence River that summer
and completely overwhelm all
the cities along the way.
The American ports are in
a position where they could
refuse entry to the ships.
The Canadian ports
can't because they're
all part of the British empire
and the ships sailing out
of Liverpool can just come
up the Saint Lawrence.
They can't go into Boston
necessarily, or Baltimore,
or New Orleans, or New York.
Well, some do but this
is why most of them
come up the Saint Lawrence.
And minus the typhus,
these ships, you know,
are still arriving on the
shores of Italy and Greece
and all around
the Mediterranean.
And everything nasty that's
said in Europe, or here,
about refugees and immigrants
from the Middle East,
from Africa, or
Latin America-- is
said about the Irish
in the 1840s and later.
Who may have been
the first people,
I would suggest,
to come to America
who were thought of and
thought of themselves,
not as settlers or as
slaves, but immigrants.
And the template for
dissing the newest,
rawest immigrant was
first built for them.
They were dirty, noisy,
argumentative, uncontrollable.
There were too many of them.
Their religion was
impossibly weird.
They were strange.
Their language was impossible--
it was barely a language.
They were shoeless.
They were filthy.
They would change us.
We wouldn't be able
to change them.
All the things that Donald
Trump suggests about immigrants
and refugees-- and how
we should handle them--
was said about the Irish.
You're [INAUDIBLE].
Right?
Yeah, OK.
So I'm just to read this
little section here.
We're with two Irish teenagers.
The concept "teenager" hasn't
really been invented yet.
But they're two
15-year-old Irish people.
They live pretty rough.
They've met each
other a construction
camp in North Wales.
They've saved, or
somehow gotten the three
pounds necessary for this
transatlantic voyage.
They've gotten on the ship.
They're on a ship at the moment.
It is being weighed out of
the docklands in Liverpool.
It's under tow to a steam tug.
There's 250 Irish people aboard.
These two teenagers,
Fergus and Molly,
have no clue really
where America is.
They've heard it's
four days across.
40 days across.
They're afraid to ask anyone
and reveal their ignorance.
They don't really know
where they're going.
But they know they
are going, and so life
seems wild and crazy and modern
and completely unexpected.
"On this morning in March on
the Mersey docklands in 1847,
a steam tug was towing Laramie
out through the busy traffic
of steamers, ships, and barges.
Sailors armed with pipes
went below hunting stowaways
while the immigrants were
herded up a pair of ladders
and squeezed into the
ship's narrow foredeck.
Sailors stood guard
at the ladders,
and a clerk from
the shipping agent
began calling out
names-- checking them off
against the passenger list.
They were packed so
tight on the peak
that people were lifting
children onto the rails.
'Oh man, this is awful business.
I don't like this at
all,' Mollie gasped.
Never would he have
pressed cattle so close.
To distract himself
from grasping
panic he could feel
rising in his throat,
he stared up through
masts, spars, and rigging
to the white sky.
Can you control the song
of fear in your head?
It never really goes away.
You are wound with it--
like a French ticker.
After hearing their names
and displaying their tickets,
they were allowed to climb
back to the main deck
where they stood along
the crowded rail.
Tugs were buzzing up
and down the river,
paddlewheels flashing,
iron muzzles smoking.
Laramie's bow sliced across
the Mersey ferry's wake,
a track of yellow fizz.
The ferry, packed
with red cattle
entranced, probably heading
for the railway works.
The sailors who had gone
below hunting stowaways
returned empty handed.
The river was opening wide and
green, marled with whitecaps.
Their bow began
to rise and fall.
And some people were seasick
on the deck or over the side.
Looking up you saw
sailors walking out
the yards, high above the
deck, bare feet on foot ropes.
The sails were still bundled
in long white canvas rolls.
Seabirds floated over the
ship, crying bitterly.
The breeze smelled
of salt and kelp.
And the ship ahead of
Laramie dropped her towline
and filled her sails.
Clouds of pale canvas blooming
as she started to roll.
Im long me measaim, he thought.
A ship I am.
A little boat was
maneuvering alongside.
One of the boatman tossed
a line caught by a sailor.
And the orange-seller
girls began
going over the side
on a rope ladder,
dropping neatly into the
little boat which fell off,
raising a red triangle of sail
and making for the Birkenhead
Shore.
'Goodbye old England,
you fucker,' Molly said.
'Goodbye iron men, hard
roads, bad sleep, sickness.'
He looked at her profile--
small nose, strong chin.
She was gall.
She was bold.
Her warm skin-- he
loved her scent.
Her clear tough
directness of thought.
She was passion
for staying alive.
'Goodbye old Kelly,'
he heard her say.
'Goodbye you heartless,
fucking Muldoon.'
Laramie's yards were
braced and the sails
filled with a cracking sound.
And the ship began to surge.
The towline was cast
away and passengers
began cheering wildly
as the tug fell off.
Laramie began to
roll and the cheering
turned to terrified screaming
as the world dipped.
He heard Molly whoop for joy.
Cutting loose the
old, the everything,
the country of the waves
now-- green and wild."
This is The O'Briens and
I'm just gonna go through.
I always think Les O'Brien
sounds like an Australian poet.
But it's actually the
name of my book in French.
These are the O'Briens.
There's just a couple of-- some
of them are kind of spooky.
Uncle Jack.
Frankie.
That's a wild one-- I don't know
quite what was happening there,
but that's my mother.
It's not my father.
-Are you sure?
[LAUGHTER]
-Timing is off.
That's the church where my
grandfather was first warden
and that's the
coffin of his son.
You don't find too many
family pictures of funerals.
But we've got them.
We're gonna leave
that one up there.
OK, these are two of
the O'Briens-- daughters
of John Joseph O'Brien.
So great-granddaughters
of the famine guy.
They're both named
Mary but one is
called Frankie O'Brien-- my
mother with the Black Watch
cap, glengarry cap.
The other is my
Aunt [? Bobby. ?]
My second novel was inspired
to a considerable degree
by these photographs.
There's more of them.
And by things I knew and did
not know about my grandfather--
John Joseph O'Brien's-- life
and the lives of his children.
There were certain
moments in their history
I wished to explore,
and it seemed
to be the best way
was through fiction.
One theme in the O'Brien's
20th century history
that interested me was people
starting backwoods poor
and becoming metropolitan rich.
This sometimes happens to
third generation immigrants.
It happened to my grandfather.
Another O'Brien's
theme is silence.
What was talked about, and
what was not talked about.
Silence is of course
a great Irish theme.
I was interested in
silence, not silence
applied to the experience
of war-- specifically
the divide that separated young
men who went off to the Second
World War and were
separated from their wives,
sisters, and
girlfriends who stayed
in a safe provincial
city like Montreal.
I grew up surrounded
by these men and women.
The adults of my
childhood-- many of the men
had been junior officers
in militia battalions
raised in Montreal-- The
Regiment de Maisonneuve,
the Royal Highland
Regiment of Canada--
my mother's wearing that one--
the Royal Montreal Regiment,
the Fusiliers Mont-Real.
These men were at the sharp
end of the war in Europe
in '43-'45.
They carried this experience
home to a provincial city,
and were strongly encouraged
to-- without any fuss--
fit themselves back into
bourgeois Canadian society
that did not really own
a language in which what
these men had seen,
what they had done,
or what have been done to
them, could be discussed
or even mentioned.
So they didn't mention.
For decades they
kept silent-- mostly.
Definite signs of strain
appeared over the years.
Cracks began to show.
But this was Canada, and a
class and a Catholic generation
that believed in not talking
about the most important
of things which were
mysteries and could only
be profaned by talking.
But when these men were
very old, the rules changed.
Or maybe they just
forgot the rules.
And they began
spilling things to me--
a nephew, a godson--
because I was interested
and because I asked them.
And when they were really
old and losing their minds
and everything else
was melting away,
certain quite horrific
snapshots came out of the war.
My image for it was like
this-- everything else kind
of melting away like
wax from a candle
and this igneous intrusion left.
The stuff that happened to
you when you're 18 or 19 or 20
in Belgium and Holland
and Germany and France
was there-- hard rock.
Hard rock.
Images imprinted
on the brain that
had not seen the light of day
in 50 years and hadn't faded.
And when I say snapshots
I mean stories.
But I mean stories without
the structure of anecdotes.
Without beginnings,
middles or endings.
Stories fresh and unexamined.
Stories without meanings
assigned to them.
Raw stuff still
there, terribly fresh
and unexamined half
a century later.
This became one of the
themes in The O'Briens
which is a novel about
how much of themselves--
some people, my people
anyway-- seemed to need
to hide, even from themselves.
And I'm going to read a little
piece from The O'Briens.
I like writing
letters in novels.
And what I'm going to
read to you is a letter.
And the guy writing is- his
name is Jean Taschereau.
He's from a bourgeois
French-Canadian background--
Montreal.
He's writing to his wife,
who is Margo O'Brien who
was back in Montreal.
And he's writing from
Sicily in the summer of 1943
where this little
Canadian Army has just
encountered the [GERMAN]
for the first time.
And they've realized,
after this three
weeks, what war really means.
And they've realized
also that most of them
are not going to survive this.
The numbers are
not in their favor.
It's going to be something.
So war has gone very rapidly
from being an adventure
to being something else.
And he's writing his wife.
[READING IN FRENCH]
I'm going to read it in English.
"Margo, ma chere, this letter
is to be the wings of a dove
and somehow fly between us.
But it's no bird, this letter.
My pen is almost
dry, so is my mouth.
I cannot speak.
Haven't had a decent
thought in days.
I'm trying to shake
myself out like to sheets
we stripped from the bed
that morning in Maine.
Shook them, left them in
a bundle for the charwoman
to wash and wring and hang where
the sun and the clean breeze
would cure them.
You will never get me
clean, Margo, I'm afraid.
The sun here is the same
sun as in Maine or Canada.
I would not believe it,
but I know it's true.
There's a rifleman in
Lieutenant Trudeau's platoon,
Private Blais, a farmer-- no,
a farmer's son from Arthabaska.
I'll tell you about him later.
Planes overhead--
our planes always.
The Germans possess
none apparently.
They say we own the sky.
The people from
Brigade say we have
beaten the Germans, only they
do not know they are beaten.
And therefore we, the infantry,
will have to walk to Germany
and remind them
again-- every mile,
every farm, every village,
on each street corner.
What clothes do you wear?
Do your fingers
touch this paper?
Does the ink speak to you?
How exactly are we
connected, Margo?
I feel more of a connection to
certain bullets than to you.
I'm thinking of your wrists now.
I once knew my wife
down to her bones.
Do you have a sweet
tan this summer?
Comme une huronne?
Whatever sense I had,
whatever solidity I
inherited from my
Norman ancestors,
has been beaten out of me I
think, in this growling ground,
This month of things bursting.
Let me dispose of my
adjectives, please.
In your arms, please
let me release them.
Bloody.
silly, fecal, loud,
beaten, red, terror.
You see I have
slipped into nouns,
so let me deliver a few more.
You don't have to
unwrap these, Margo.
Just sign for them, then
you can put them away.
Child, children, machine
gun, anti-tank, .303, 88,
tree-burst, counterattack, head
wound, prisoner, neck wound,
aorta, femoral artery, battle.
And men of good cheer
are singing now.
In this, our "rest area,"
the men of the Regiment
Vingt-Deuxieme are
being fed hamburger and
[READING IN FRENCH]
Are your thigh
still your thighs?
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
O ma femme.
Is the little girl-- no
I shall not think of her.
I do not want her
appearing in this place.
Your cunt.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
Je t'en prie.
Me, I want you on your back.
I want your belly sweet
and warm, like sugar pie.
Anti-tank.
Howitzer.
To lose your head out here--
c'est tellement facile.
The 88s come cracking
through olive groves
at dawn, high velocity very flat
trajectory, dismembering trees.
What kills is often
not the shell itself,
the bits of riflemen, and
splinters of rocks and trees.
The thing comes at you like
a girl you want, like a cunt,
so sweet and so indirect.
Soldiers in rifle
companies are killed
by pieces of other soldiers
in rifle companies.
Arms, boots, knees.
I tell my platoon leaders,
it's another reason
to keep the boys
from bunching up
which is what they will always
do it first, like cattle,
no matter their training.
Think of your pals, I tell
them, as shrapnel-- dangerous.
Watch out for those
flying steel helmets.
A splinter of leg bone
can do astonishing damage.
My Sergeant Major on the
road approaching Catania.
There.
I want you to cover me.
Three young German
boys in a staff car
on a road through the mountains.
As little Lieutenant
Duclos reported,
he fully intended to offer
them a chance of surrender.
Only Corporal Dextraxe
offered them a lively talk
from his Tommy gun instead.
And the young lieutenant,
the jesuitical prig,
straight out of College
Brebeuf, was quite cool
delivering his report.
He'll lose no sleep
over dead Boches.
It was the corporal--
one of our best,
a rugged forester
from Megantic--
who was trembling and cursing.
Their company commander,
this is who I am.
I am not your husband
anymore, Margo.
I don't belong to anyone
but the tree-bursts.
And right now the greasy air
floating from the hamburger
tent where survivors gorge.
Replacements are
due up tomorrow--
for my company 17 fresh men.
Everyone is tired.
The riflemen assure me there
are beautiful, famished girls
alive in the cellars of Messina
who will do it with vigor
for a piece of cheese.
And afterwards offer
you a bottle of Marsala
for one lousy Sweet
Caps cigarette.
That Blais, the
riflemen I mentioned,
the imbecile got his
girl pregnant last year
just before going overseas.
Her old man put her off to
the gray nuns in Montreal
where she had the child and
was forced to give it up,
and is now a slavie scrubbing
floors for the sisters
and very miserable.
Her letter, which he
showed me, is pathetic.
Do they send girls in
the country to school?
This one hardly makes
herself understood.
In any case, when you
go to the convent,
see the Mother Superior to
determine what can be done.
You may use the name of
my uncle, the bishop.
The girl is Lucie
something-or-other
from Tingwick, 15
or 16 years of age.
Blais is a good chap and insists
they will marry if he survives.
Perhaps you can find
her a maid's position.
With the wages they're paying
at the factories these days,
I expect in Westmount
you are short of slaves.
Oh my dear, I am shook up,
and no one but you knows it.
Forgive.
I give you my blood, my heart,
my kisses for our girl."
OK.
Someone said, this is a novel,
it's coming out next month,
and it spooked me.
When I showed it
to a class I was
teaching this summer, the kind
of prototype of the jacket.
Somebody look at it
said, Larry and Me?
It's actually Carry Me.
And we're hoping
it's going to work.
It'll be published next month.
Larry and Me is about war,
passion, and escapism.
It's fiction and it
also borrows some things
from my father's
complicated life.
Settings were
inspired considerably
by these photographs and by
the stories attached to them.
That's my father--
the little guy down
in the corner-- and his father--
my Anglo-Irish-German father
and his German father-- on the
Isle of Wight on a sunny summer
day in 1912.
These pictures all kind of
wreak of Edwardian summer--
the last light thereof.
This is my grandparents
on the Isle of Wight.
This is the house they lived
in-- did not own, but lived
in-- when my dad was born
on the Isle of Wight.
All these pictures were taken
before the first World War.
That's Dad in the baby dress.
Again, happy summer
guy, happy summer.
This is my grandfather
looking out
through a telescope--
which I still
have-- at ships in the Solent
and in the body of water
coming into Portsmouth and
Southampton Harbor-- which got
him into great trouble, this.
I'm going to get
mixed-up here because I'm
talking about my father and I'm
talking about the protagonist--
and they're definitely
two different things.
But the protagonist
of this novel, Billy,
was born on the Isle of Wight
at the tail end of Edwardian
summer.
On the day that England
declared war in August 1914,
his German father-- my German
grandfather-- was arrested.
As about 50 men were
through the British Isles--
on the orders of
Winston Churchill who
was the First Lord of
the Admiralty-- arrested
as a German naval spy and
threatened with execution.
He was not a German spy.
He had a telescope and he
liked looked at sailing ships.
But there was a lot of
hysteria around at the time.
So the charges were dropped.
But he was interned for 4 and
1/2 years as an enemy alien
and then deported to Germany
in the bitter winter of 1919.
His eight-year-old son, Billy,
and Billy's Anglo-Irish mother
went into exile
in that very sour
and defeated Germany with him.
The wife and son did not
speak a word of German.
She never really learned.
She said she spoke it.
My father said no
one understood her.
My dad-- and the
character in this book--
learn their way into German,
and Germany, and German culture,
by reading Karl May's Winnetou
novels which are still,
I think, the most
widely published
and widely read books
in the German language.
These are Wild West tales
set on the Llano Estacado
in West Texas and New Mexico.
And they feature a noble
Apache chief, Winnetou,
and his German blood
brother-- there in buckskins--
who's Old Shatterhand.
These are phenomenally
influential in German culture.
They were Albert
Einstein's favorite books.
They were Adolf
Hitler's favorite books.
They are really,
really the reason
why when you go to the
desert in the southwest,
you're likely to meet
a pack of young Germans
in a big Cadillac having their
Winnetou experience driving
across the country.
You also meet a lot on
Indian reserves in Canada,
and getting peevish at
the First Nations people
for not having the
right shoes on when
they're doing their ceremonies
and stuff like that.
They're very German about it
My dad, and the character
in this book-- Winnetou,
was their way into German.
And the way of owning Germany.
The books were written
by a German who had never
seen North America when he
wrote them, and never is
life got further west
than Buffalo, New York.
But they are the medium through
which my father fell in love
with German language and culture
in the Frankfurt of the '20s
and with Weimar
culture generally.
Then of course
everything goes to hell
for the family in the book.
I love this shot-- because it's
just a totally ordinary street
shot-- I don't
know who took it --
of my grandfather on just
a totally ordinary day
in Frankfurt before
everything went really bad.
This is like late '20s.
This is a school which I'm not
sure that my father attended,
but a historian I
met in Frankfurt
assured me he probably did.
And this is one the places
where dreadful things happened
in 1933.
They had a wild camp here.
The SS rounded up a lot
of communists and Social
Democratic Party people
and tortured them
in the basement of
the school for weeks.
This is IG Farben
headquarters in Frankfort,
now Goethe University-- built in
the early '30s for a long time
the largest commercial
office building in Europe.
And I'll tell you a bit about
why I'm showing you this slide.
Doing research, I learned
my father's family
had lived for a
time of the estate
of a wealthy rich Jewish
family in Frankfurt, Baron von
Weinberg and his Irish wife.
The baron was the
grandson of an old clothes
dealer from Breslau.
His wife was
Anglo-Irish, and may
have been related to my
English-Irish grandmother.
I'm not sure about that.
But the Jewish baron-- as
he was called in the press--
was a chemist,
and a polo player,
one the richest men in
Germany, one of the founders
of the IT Farben cartel.
And I believe he got my father
his job at IG Farben in 1930,
the time when the German
economy was collapsing
and thousands of jobs were being
lost, including even at IG.
So so much for kind of
real family history.
The rest of the novel
really becomes a novel
and tracks less
the family story.
I learned a lot about
these two families-- my own
and the Weinbergs-- while
doing research in Frankfurt.
Carry Me becomes a book
about-- partly about Karl May,
it's real theme is
escape and escapism.
As Billy says at one point,
"In Frankfurt in 1938 escapism
was for realists, escapists
saw things plain."
And the escape
the day dreamed of
was-- This is my
father and grandfather.
He's looking it down the Rhine.
This is a week before the--
my father went back to Germany
in the summer of '39
partly in an attempt
to persuade his
parents to leave.
They were Catholic, not Jews,
and not in a particular danger.
But he wanted to get
them out of the country.
My grandfather
felt he couldn't go
because he'd be imprisoned
as an enemy alien in England
again, or in Canada.
But this is him
looking down the Rhine
a few days before
the war starts.
I think he sees the war
just coming down the Rhine.
Dad's about to get across
the border to Holland.
But escape in this
novel takes the form
of the Llano Estacado,
the imagined fantasy
of west Texas and New Mexico.
A place that is everything that
Frankfurt in the 1930s isn't.
One of the characters talks
about travelling at speed
across the emptiness and
openness of the Llano Estacado
and feeling the drag of history
being burnt off his wings.
This is a very romantic
idea-- a very German idea.
And of course history does not
evaporate, no matter how fast
or how far you go.
History stays with you.
German romantics
usually in badly.
And the quick piece
from this novel
that I'm going to
end up reading is not
set in the Llano Estacado,
but it's in Mecklenburg,
northeast of Berlin, in 1937.
These two young people
in their mid '20s
have left Berlin
just get out of it.
And maybe it's kind of a trial
run for getting out of it
and going to the Llano Estacado.
"An August afternoon in
my little car with her,
our windows cranked
down, salt scented air
that tasted like freedom.
We both like to move.
There weren't many
cars on the road
then, especially
to the Northeast.
The regime was
planning Autobahn, even
starting constructing
them, but you
couldn't travel on them yet.
The existing roads weren't
much good but were often empty.
We could go as fast as we liked.
Though the wanderer had
nothing like the feline power
of [INAUDIBLE]
Mercedes, she might
clock at top speed of
90 kilometers an hour,
but only on a smooth
road and with a tailwind.
Still that seemed fast
enough, breezing down
empty roads in Mecklenburg.
Whenever they were late we
made a point to stop and swim.
She disliked bathing costumes--
said they were pornographic,
refused to wear them.
So I had to swim naked too.
We stopped to go
birding in a marsh.
That world is closed off now--
behind the Iron Curtain--
rearranged.
Maybe the marsh is still there.
We're on a walkway
across the wetlands.
Silver gray planks
strung together
to make a narrow wooden path
perhaps a kilometer in length--
so narrow if we
meet anyone coming
in the opposite directions,
passing will be tricky.
This is a well known
birding locale.
Hunters come up
here too, in season.
But in summer it's people
like us from Berlin.
Or down from Rostock,
armed only with binoculars,
hoping to spot whooper
cranes, egrets, night herons.
She is ahead of me,
wearing a summer frock,
white and brown
checks sewn in Berlin
by her expatriate
Parisian dressmaker.
Her shoulders are
bare, sunburned,
peeling a little bit.
On her feet a pair
of green sandals.
And around her neck, a strap
from my father's old Navy
binoculars-- the pair used
for watching sailboats out
in the channel.
In Charlottenburg,
we use the binoculars
to play a game she
calls Who's a Rotter.
Zeroing in on patrons at cafe
tables across the street,
we have 10 seconds to
decide if they are a.
full blooded Nazis, b.
half-hearted Nazis, or c.
not Nazis at all.
She claims to be Olympics
caliber at this sport,
but there is no way of
independently confirming
our scores.
In the wide fragrant marsh it's
not party members, but egrets,
and herons, black
storks, and whooper
swans we're looking for.
We've left behind the city and
it's sea of rippling flags--
red and white with a jagged
black cross in the center,
making hideous
use of the breeze.
But the marsh is
a separate world.
The wide sky is hazy, a
gray silver sky with rain
possible, but if so, warm rain.
I'm following her
along duckboards.
The planks are silvery, and
squeak and bend underfoot,
as we tread upon them.
The marsh is a sea of
silver-green grasses
and the wind ripples the
grass with a sibilant sound
like bedsheets tearing.
There's no one else in
sight, not a single person.
It's marsh, so you
wouldn't expect a crowd.
But it still seems
extraordinarily
empty from the point of
view of city folk like us.
And my nose has picked up a
first tangy scent of the sea.
And she stopped so abruptly
I almost bump into her.
'Egret,' she says,
raising the glasses.
The bird is stalking its next
meal-- frogs or whatever it
is egrets feed on in a marsh.
It's stride is
awkward and hesitant.
And while she peers
through the binoculars
I place my hands on her hips.
It is the first time
I've touched her
in such an intimate
and possessive way
outside the bedroom, touch
her as only a lover would.
'Jolly good luck to see
an egret,' she says.
Two young people breezing
through the wide countryside
an open car, walking on
duck boards across a marsh,
breathing the sifting
fragrance of the sea.
It sounds charming romance.
Was it?
I don't know.
I never had
perspective from which
to analyze the relationship.
It didn't occur to me to try.
Most people in those days
were confused and startled
by relationships--
young men were anyway.
We never imagined or predicted
the depth and complexity
of our feelings about the young
woman-- about young women.
Until such feelings
overwhelmed us.
No one warned us.
We believed in privacy.
Our feelings were our own.
Words-- words were facile
things, superficial, limited.
One only spoiled one's
feelings by talking of them.
Following Karin Weinbrenner
along duckboards
set across marsh
mud and sea brine,
I did not own language
to discuss my feelings--
to put them out there in
the jargon everyone seems
able to wield today.
To put myself out there.
No.
Perhaps had I been able to
put things in plain language
it might have been plain
that things between us
were so damnably
unequal, and that I loved
her as I would never
love anyone else.
And that she loved me
as a young woman might
love a devoted brother,
a trusted bodyguard,
a horse that never
stumbles, never
shies, but takes
offenses willingly
and carries her safely across.
When we were apart and I thought
of her, I left words out of it.
What came to mind
instead were flashes
of bold color, and
sunlight, and always
an impression of
wide open country,
and the pair of
us traveling alone
together at great distance
and at great speed."
So I think rather than
going into the next book,
I think I'm going to
have to wrap up there.
I'm not going to speak
of my fourth book-- which
is very much in progress,
and the reason I'm here
at Radcliffe-- which is
partly a relief to me
because it's a bit
scary talking about work
that is in progress so much.
But I assure you that
it is, in progress.
OK, and thank you very
much for listening.